بعد الغاره الجويه المروعه على مدينه حلب
والتي اودت بحياه العشرات سادت حاله من
الفوضى حيث تبدو الغاره متعمده ووفقا
لمنظمه هيومان رايتس واتش فقد حدث هذا
الهجوم في الحادي والعشرين من هذا الشهر
وبحسب شهود عيان فان طائره المروحيه كانت
تحلق قبل ساعات من فتح المخابز ابوابها
بينما كان يصطف نحو 200 شخص في طوابير
للحصول على الخبز وبعدها اسقطت الطائره
قنبله على المكان وبينما قال العاملون في
المستشفى للمنظمه الحقوقيه ان هناك اكثر
من 20 قتيلا خلال الغاره تؤكد المنظمه انه
اصبح هناك نمط سائد لمثل هذه الهجمات
تعرضت طوابير المدنيين الذين ينتظرون امام
المخابز لما يقرب من عشر هجمات حيث
استخدمت فيها الدبابات والمروحيات وكذلك
الطائرات المقاتله الامر الذي ادى لمقتل
وجرح الحشرات غالبيتهم من المدنيين وتؤكد
هيومان رايتس واتش ان جميع هذه الحالات
موثقه وربما تكون هذه الهجمات مت متعمده
او عشوائيه وفي كلت الحالتين تعد جرائم
حرب ويعد هذا الشهر الاكثر دمويه حيث
ارتفعت في الاسبوع الماضي وتيره العنف
بشكل ملحوظ كما يؤكد نشطاء بالمعارضه فقد
عثر على اكثر من 200 جثه في منطقه داريا
احدى ضواحي دمشق بينما ادعى النظام ان
المجموعات المسلحه هي التي نفذت عمليات
القتل تلك وبعد 18 شهرا من الاحتجاجات ضد
نظام الاسد يبدو ان الجيش الحر بدا يحصل
على اسلحه اكثر فاع
لمجابهه القوات الحكوميه ووسط الازمه
الانسانيه المتفاقم يواصل الاف السوريين
النزوح بينما تبدي الدول المجاوره قلقها
حول امكانيه استيعاب المزيد من النازحين
وفي الوقت الذي يصر فيه الاسد على الحل
الامني لحسم الصراع يبدو ان المجتمع
الدولي لا يملك الكثير من الخيارات لحل
الازمه التي تتفاقم يوما بعد
يوم